but yes I was in one of your music
videos for behind these hazel yes the
wedding I was a wedding guest and yeah
there was a scene where you run down the
aisle of the church fling open the door
you don't know this part Joseph Kahn who
directed it who's like Drex movies he's
incredible and he's done a ton of my
videos no one actually told me that
there were stairs when you open the
doors and I am full on I don't know if
you've noticed so like I literally in
that video they said we want you to run
out because you're so mad cuz you're a
bridesmaid has been with no man and like
it's like okay and I was like I was like
okay so I I was in track I ran and I ran
so hard I didn't actually fall I like
flew down the stair it's like with this
giant dress didn't get one bruise thank
you now I feel like what you didn't get
to see was what I saw Kelly Clark
because the the direction for the people
at the wedding was Kelly's gonna run by
you you're shocked you're stunned
there's drama and watch her as she runs
through so we all were watching you we
watched the doors fling open and then we
watched you freefall spoilers down a set
of stairs and then there was like an odd
calm yeah and it hit the room happened
to her and I remember a boy it was like
15-second like deafening silence and
then we hear from down the stairs Mary
Kathleen Gallagher like full wedding
dress to my wedding dress yeah I was
like and I literally looked at Joseph
never like thanks to the heads up the
whole stairs to the room that could have
gone a different way we actually have
video of Danny's like mowing in my video
and
okay
there wait can you see me no there am
there I am yeah there is a very M hold
on
there I am I think it's not a starring
role my early acting career I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this